forest fires storms and floods wreaked
devastation across Europe in 2017 and
2018 the EU Civil Protection mechanism
was built to respond to these disasters
now Parliament is pushing to upgrade the
system so the EU can act more quickly
and efficiently in the event of a
disaster a mechanism of civil protection
want to strengthen also the cooperation
between member states the law also sets
up a new apparatus could rescue
it's a reserve of resources such as
forest firefighting planes special water
pumps field hospitals and medical teams
the aim is to provide support for member
states who need more resources to cope
with the disaster especially if several
countries are dealing with the same
emergency at the same time the civil
protection mechanism is based on the
subsidiarity principle that's why it's
up to the Member States to activate it
when they are not able to face
emergencies the upgraded legislation
will prevent billions of euros worth of
damage to infrastructure across Europe
and above all protect citizens
you
[Music]